[Music]
welcome back
so today we're going to be talking about
turbulence modeling
which is one of the most important areas
of high performance computing and
computational science
so when we want to design a new aircraft
or an automobile
or a turbine engine the blades for a
turbine
generally speaking we're going to need
to simulate some fluid flow equations
to estimate quantities of interest like
the lift and drag
on the wings and the body of an aircraft
for example
now we in general might want to solve
the
full navier-stokes equations for with a
direct numerical simulation
which would resolve all of the scales in
space and time
so here i'm going to show you one of my
favorite movies of a direct
numerical simulation but it is typically
very difficult to simulate these
fluid flow equations over the entire
aircraft or over an entire automobile
so instead what researchers often do is
zoom into a particular piece
like this section of an airfoil
and solving the full flow field
equations for
this section of the airfoil is still
exceedingly expensive
okay so this is a super computer
computation
i believe it'll show here in a little
bit how many hours
so this is the grid that's being
generated um
and a preliminary reynolds average navy
or stoke solution is used to extract
values for the condition the boundary
conditions this is 35
million core hours okay so extremely
expensive
just to get one section of an airfoil
let alone the full
the full aircraft okay and so
typically it is too expensive to run
direct numerical simulations or simulate
all of the scales of the navier-stokes
equations all at once
for something like an aircraft or a ship
okay and so even with moore's law
of exponentially growing computer power
it will still take at this current rate
a hundred or more years to be able to
simulate the largest scale turbulent
problems
at all resolutions in space and time
and that's just for one run of the
simulation
now when you want to do design
optimization inverse optimization for
example to design the shape of a wing
you're having to run many many many of
these simulations in an iterative loop
and so it'll be even harder
to use this for design optimization and
real-time control
and so that's where turbulence modeling
comes in instead of simulating
all of the scales of the navier-stokes
equations in space and time
we're going to make approximations that
allow us to get engineering quantities
of interest
much much more efficiently okay so
that's what i'm going to talk about
today
and this is going to lead in very
naturally to modern methods
in machine learning and deep learning
which
is really stands to revolutionize
turbulence modeling
okay so i'm going to jump in and some of
this is going to be a review from the
last few weeks lectures
so the reynolds averaging approach to
the navier-stokes equations
and we're going to kind of zoom into one
turbulent example here
is to take the navy or stokes equations
in this case the incompressible
navier-stokes equations so the momentum
equation
and the mass continuity equation and
um what we're going to do is look at the
averaged velocity field so this is an
unsteady
time varying velocity field just like
that movie i showed you
but we're going to average in time and
we're going to try to model these
time averaged quantities so uh
reynolds osborne reynolds the same
reynolds as the reynolds number
proposed this decomposition of this
separation of your velocity
field u which is a function of space and
time
into a time averaged component u bar
and the fluctuating components u prime
and so
u bar is just a time average and u prime
is everything
else that's not in that time average
and the idea is we're going to take this
decomposition
plug it into the navier-stokes equations
and average
those equations to try to get a
simplified equation of just this mean
flow
uh variable u bar and what we hope
is that we get a simpler set of
equations to solve that is less
expensive
but gives us large scale information
about our engineering system like the
average drag or the average lift
or whether or not my airfoil might the
flow over my airfoil is going to
separate or not
okay and so when you plug
this reynolds decomposition into for
example the mass continuity equation now
this is a review i'm just going to walk
you through really really briefly
you essentially get six terms because
this is the
divergence of u so you know partial u
partial x
plus partial v partial y plus partial w
partial z or z both in the mean
and the fluctuating components and so
there's a lot of tricks we can play and
i've shown you this before
if i take and i time average this entire
equation so every term here
well the time average of a time average
is just itself so these three terms
remain
unchanged but the time average of my
fluctuating derivatives goes to zero
because those uh by definition when i
averaged them they were zero they were
everything that was not in the mean flow
so when i average i kill those three
terms
which implies that my mean
flow divergence is equal to zero
now by a similar argument if these three
terms are equal to zero
then it stands to reason that these
three terms before i time average
were also equal to zero and so it means
that the divergence of my fluctuating
components
are uh equal to zero so this is the kind
of uh
game you can play when you do this
reynolds average
uh navy or stoke so this reynolds
decomposition so i take my
uh my decomposition i plug it into my
continuity equation
and i find these two equations that the
divergence of my mean flow
and my fluctuating velocity field are
both equal to zero
okay now when we do the same thing for
the momentum equation
it's a little bit more complicated so
i'll just briefly walk through here
and this is going to set up the
turbulence closure problem that we're
going to look at
in the next half of the video so this is
just
the x component of the momentum equation
so this is you know
in general three equations for u v and w
so i'm just looking at the first
equation for the x momentum
and when i take my reynolds
decomposition and i plug it into
my navier-stokes equations what we find
is kind of this pretty nasty expression
here this is what i get when i just plug
this
into into my momentum equation and we're
going to do the same thing as before
we're going to time average everything
but before we do that we're going to
notice that this term here this
u bar t that is always zero
because um this term is always zero
because u bar is not time varying so
this term is going to go away
and then when we time average everything
a lot of terms drop out and i i went
through this
uh kind of in another lecture so if you
want the details you can find it but
basically
all of the fluctuating uh components and
all of the terms with one fluctuating
component
are gonna drop out and so all that's
left
are these average quantities and these
quantities that have two fluctuating
components
in their averages and so you can kind of
collect all of these terms
like this so massively simplified
equation
but remember we wanted to find an
equation that was simpler
that was just in terms of this mean flow
u bar because those give us kind of the
big
average quantities we might care about
for design optimization
but this equation is not just a function
of my mean flow variables
it also has these turbulent fluctuations
u prime u prime x and
v prime u prime y things like that which
vary in time and space
so i need to know what's happening in
the full turbulent flow field
to solve for these uh average quantities
i care about
and so in general understanding and
modeling these terms here
is going to be central to the closure
modeling problem
i'm going to i'm going to simplify just
one step further so you can use this
identity here
which is basically just the chain rule
of these middle terms would give you the
left terms
plus the right terms i've written it
this way
because these are the terms that we have
on the left here
and notice that every term in this right
column if i added those
up it would be the same as little u
prime times the divergence of vector u
prime
and remember that our divergence of our
fluctuating components is zero
so these three terms die out and so i
can replace
these three sums uh the sum of these
three terms with
these terms here and so i'm going to
replace it like this
and i'm writing all of my partials out
explicitly instead of with subscripts
and this is the u component the x
component of my
reynolds average navier stokes equations
okay good so i'm just going through and
kind of showing you this is all
rigorously
derived from the equations of motion uh
people have been doing this for a
hundred years
okay and these terms here
are called the reynold stresses and in
particular i mean the u prime u prime
bar
and u prime v prime bar those are the
reynold stresses
because when i take their spatial
gradient they have
units of force per volume just like
these stresses
down here the pressure and the viscous
diffusion
forces and so these can be kind of
thought of
as generalizations of
these pressure forces and diffusion
forces but due to these turbulent
fluctuations they're creating a stress
on the mean flow that we want to model
good and the whole closure problem is
trying to
approximate these mean flow quantities
without
considering these turbulent fluctuations
so what we want to do is essentially
find a model for these reynold stresses
in terms of the mean flow that's the
whole name of the game
and that's what at least reynolds
average navy or stokes closure modeling
is all about
good so here are our reynold stresses um
again the x component of the momentum
equation
you can do some other things i want to
just show you um
we're going to go into different closure
models in a minute
but there's a couple of concepts that i
want to show you that are really really
important
so you can take your reynolds stresses
and we're going to try to build a model
for these reynolds stresses now
so what i can do is i can take my
reynolds average navy or stokes
equations i take my
my reynolds decomposition plug it into
the navy or stokes equations
and now instead of just averaging i'm
going to multiply by my fluctuating
component u prime
and then average and you get something
pretty ugly here
okay so i'm not going to walk you
through this you can derive this
yourself
or even better go download lex
smith's notes from princeton mae 553
and you can walk through exactly how
this works but so again a lot of these
terms are going to simplify
and notice that you get
for uh for these u prime u prime reynold
stress terms
now i have terms that include three
fluctuating components u
prime u prime and u prime sub x and so
what this means is that when i want to
build a model for these reynold stresses
which are the second moments of my
turbulent fluctuations
i'm going to need to include these third
order moments these third moments
uh or triple correlations of my
turbulent fluctuations
and this never ends if i took this
equation and i multiplied it by u prime
and i time averaged
i could get an equation for these kind
of triple stresses
but those triple stresses would have
fourth order correlations
that they depend on and the fourth order
correlations would have fifth order
correlations
and this never ends this is a
fundamentally a mathematical closure
problem
and it's kind of related to lots of
other closure problems we've seen like
the coupeman operator and things like
that
okay so i just wanted to show you it's
not that easy to just you know build a
simple model for these reynold stresses
this kind of just gets worse and worse
the more you try to close the problem
there is an alternative approach which
i'm going to walk through
which is essentially here i'm going to
write this here so so going back to our
our x momentum equation you can write
this in kind of
einstein notation like this so this is
actually all three of the equations
um so u i if i equals 1 that would be
the x equation
if i equals 2 that would be the y
equation and if i equals 3 that would be
the z
or z equation and so you can write
the whole kind of reynolds average navy
or stokes problem like this
where i've pulled my partial derivative
out and all of these terms are my
stresses
okay i've got my pressure my viscous
diffusion
and my my reynold stresses here okay
good and so one of the the things that
people use
the most often to model these systems
is called the turbulent kinetic energy
so what you want to do is try to
understand
you have all those turbulent
fluctuations how
are those being driven by the mean flow
and how does the mean flow
get driven by those turbulent
fluctuations so there's this constant
trade-off of energy
between the mean flow kinetic energy
and the turbulent kinetic energy and
turbulence closure models
are essentially going to try to model
those reynold stresses
by modeling how this energy flow occurs
only using mean flow
variables so we define the turbulent
kinetic energy here k
and this is going to be the k from k
epsilon models and k
omega models that you've probably heard
of in the past
and with a little bit of math you can
essentially derive this turbulent
kinetic energy equation
again this is done really nicely in lex
smith's
course notes but this is what you get
when you essentially derive the equation
for
for the time variation of k and i'm
going to walk you through what each of
these terms means
okay so this is the rate of change of my
turbulent kinetic energy in time
and it's driven by these these
these terms on the right so we have
convection by the mean flow
essentially k is being convected by
these large mean flow
currents i have pressure diffusion
i'm not going to talk about what all of
these terms mean uh
i have something called turbulent
transport which again involves this
triple
uh moment here this kind of u prime u
prime u prime
and again subscript here u i u i
1 would be u u sub 2 would be v
u sub 3 would be w and partial
x i that means partial x partial y
partial z
okay the
del squared k del x square is just
you know normal viscous transport this
is the term i really want to talk about
this turbulence production term
which is my reynold stresses times the
gradient of my mean flow
i'll talk about this in a minute and
then i have dissipation terms
basically uh turbulence just dissipating
into heat
okay and so there's this really nice
figure that i i saw in lex's notes but
he pulled it from bradshaw's 1971 book
which basically shows you know all of
these different
uh terms are kind of competing to grow
or to shrink the turbulent kinetic
energy and to trade
uh energy from the mean flow into energy
from into the turbulent scales and vice
versa
so that's what we're going to be
modeling and i'll point out this
turbulence production is one of
i think the most important for me
conceptually
because it says essentially that our
turbulence kinetic energy
increases when we have a large
shear in the mean flow so if i have an
average flow like a shear layer where i
have really really fast flow
and slow flow there is a large shear
between those two flows that's going to
drive the development of
lots of turbulent it's going to pump
energy into the turbulent scales
from this big mean flow and so for me
this has been very useful
conceptually to understand what types of
features
in a turbulent flow drive the small
scale turbulence
so anytime the flow separates over your
wing and creates a shear layer
you know it's going to be driving lots
of turbulent
energy production okay good
so back to the reynolds averaging
problem and back to our closure problem
so we want to model the reynold stresses
as a function of the mean flow
if we can do that then we can solve this
efficiently
and we can get mean flow quantities like
the average lift the average drag
things like that okay
and the simplest approach kind of
the approach actually that people still
take today this is an old approach
is called eddy viscosity modeling so
basically what you're going to do
is you're going to say that all of those
tiny little uh
turbulent scales that generate those
reynold stresses
they basically act like viscosity in the
navy or stokes equations they basically
act
like this diffusion term here
and so we want to find kind of the
effective viscosity
of the turbulence and so this was
actually proposed a long time ago by
business in 1877
is that we can model uh these turbulent
fluctuations as some
eddy viscosity some effective viscosity
nu sub t
times uh this kind of you know
uh gradients of the mean flow so partial
u partial y
plus partial v partial x for a 2d flow
like this
uh channel flow up here okay and this
gets a little more complicated
in 3d you can essentially in three
dimensions write
each of these components here and i
picked up this little term which is
two-thirds the kinetic energy
times the dirac delta function in case i
want to look at the stress
u1 u1 bar or u2 u2
r or u3 u3 bar i'll need to consider
this term here
but the big idea is that we are modeling
all of those turbulent scales
in terms of this effective viscosity
this eddy viscosity model
nu times mean flow quantities
and by far the simplest model is just
say
nu t is a constant so you could totally
just pick a constant
tune this empirically for a pipe flow or
a channel flow or a shear flow
and plug that constant in and it will do
you know all right
it's not a great model it's a pretty bad
model
prandtl made a really important
correction
to this eddie viscosity model which
essentially
says that this this effective viscosity
changes
in space depending on the mean flow
shear
okay so he was considering boundary
layers where the boundary layer
thickness
grows and where the turbulence evolves
both you know in space
and away from the the boundary from the
wall
and so prandtl proposed uh this kind of
mixing length hypo hypothesis that
essentially this effective viscosity
is a function of this mixing length
squared
times the um the shear in the y
direction
so this kind of gradient of u in the y
direction
and so if you plug this in for our eddy
viscosity
you get a better model
for for these wall bounded flows okay
for boundary layer flows
this is our mixing length and you can
kind of tune that empirically or make
arguments for what that mixing length is
again that's like a whole thing
you would do and then there are a whole
family of
more sophisticated models that try to
model
this this turbulent kinetic energy more
effectively
okay so so those kind of eddy viscosity
models the simple
constant and prandtl models are very
very simple that's like before computers
this is what you would do now that we
have computers are these two pde
or two equation turbulence models like k
epsilon or k
omega and here k again is the turbulent
kinetic energy it's that equation i
derived for you
and epsilon is the rate of dissipation
of the turbulent kinetic energy
so in that big tke equation i showed you
before you could basically lump all of
the terms that go to dissipate
k and you call those epsilon and then
you write a new differential equation
for epsilon what causes it to grow and
shrink
and you can essentially solve these two
pdes with
your uh rand's equations
and you get a better uh more accurate
prediction of your
of your turbulent mean field and this
would be the eddy
viscosity nu as a function of k and
epsilon the the density of the fluid rho
and this constant c mu now c mu has been
empirically determined to be about .09
but this is the formula now
again k epsilon models like if you run
any commercial turbulent software
there's an option you know for what
turbulence model you want to
to select or to use and k epsilon is one
of the standard models
but it's been known for a long time that
this is not a good model when you have
adverse pressure gradients or reverse
flow
so for example if i have flow over a
wing
and my wings at a high angle of attack
or it's a droop wing or there's you know
a gust
i'm gonna get this separated flow uh
structure that's gonna vortex shed cause
vortex shedding
and if i look at my average flow my mean
flow it's going to look like a
separation bubble
it's going to look like the flow
separates and reattaches at some point
and if i look at my boundary layer
profile upstream
it's a normal boundary layer profile but
right in that separation bubble you see
that the flow reverses
before it catches up to the free stream
so this is a recirculation bubble
or a region of reverse flow this is
called an adverse pressure gradient
that's causing the flow to reverse now
these k epsilon models are notoriously
bad
for these kinds of separated flows but
this is a really important problem
that people actually care about in
aircraft design is predicting
when my flow is going to separate when
my wing is going to stall
that's a critical thing to predict and
so these are just not that great of
models for that
okay so another really really useful
model in the literature is the spellart
almiraz
almaraz model which is a one equation
model
so more efficient than k epsilon
and it's actually been tailored for
aerospace applications i'm sorry
autocorrect killed one of the ls here
this is two l's alma raz
here this is one of the most cited
papers
in aia history so over 10 000 times this
has been cited because it's so
useful and it has very nice physical
derivations of the tuning constants of
this model
and again it's been specifically
tailored for aerospace applications like
uh predicting the lift and drag on wings
uh
and on you know on on aircraft so you
can use this model
for designing your aircraft you know you
can change or tweak
uh you know the geometry of your wing
and fairly rapidly
figure out what these average quantities
are going to be and then re-optimize and
redesign based on these predictions
so this one's really really useful
cornerstone of aerospace engineering
okay good so that was turbulence closure
modeling using the reynolds average navy
or stokes equations
now for the the rest of this i'm going
to tell you about a whole
different perspective called large eddy
simulation or les
and these are really kind of the two big
families of turbulence closure modeling
you have your reynolds average navy or
stokes
and your large eddy simulations and les
was proposed
more recently so you remember business
was 1877.
large eddy simulation was proposed much
more recently in the computational era
by smagarinsky
in 1963 and smagerinsky
i believe was the director of the gfdl
lab at princeton the geophysical fluid
dynamics lab
and so their concern was trying to
simulate and predict these
large large earth-scale geophysical
flows like the atmosphere how a
hurricane forms
and so again too complicated to simulate
all scales
sma gorinsky proposed that instead of
solving
the navier-stokes equations on a very
very high resolution grid
we would solve it on a much lower
resolution grid
and essentially low pass filter or
coarse grain the navier-stokes equations
so instead of you know this would be far
too expensive even for our biggest
supercomputers to solve
all of the scales of an earth scale flow
so what we're going to do
is coarsen the grid and average
sorry filter the navy or stokes
equations onto that coarse grid and
solve those equations
and when i say you know a coarse grid
i mean you know maybe you take the
surface of the earth
and you chop it up into boxes a hundred
square kilometers
or maybe a hundred kilometers by a
hundred kilometers
that would be a course model and every
10 or 20 years we're able to refine that
model down and get finer and finer
resolution
because our again more is law and our
super computers are getting bigger and
bigger
but it's still going to be a long time
before we can actually
resolve all of the scales that matter
so we low-pass filter our navy or stokes
equations onto the coarse grid
and this has its own closure problem
which is essentially
the non-linearity in the flow and i'm
not going to derive
this kind of filtering it's pretty
mathematically involved but the
non-linearity
effectively couples your spatial scales
so your big structures
depend through nonlinear terms on your
little scales and your little scales
depend through the nonlinear term on
your big scales
through that conduction term in your
neighbor your stokes equations
and so we need to model what's happening
under the hood in each of these little
course boxes each of these little coarse
grid boxes
has real turbulent fluid variations
happening
and so we need a model for the sub grid
scale these are called
sgs or subgrid scale models
and in principle we do the exact same
thing for les
or or we have kind of the same tool set
for les that we did for rans
we're going to use eddie viscosity
modeling and things like that
we're going to make hypotheses about
what's happening uh
behind the scenes or underneath this
course grid
you know in the in the full resolution
field and we're going to make
approximations about how that's
approximately
acting like an effective viscosity and
this goes back to
this picture of the kolmogorov energy
cascade
where you essentially have you know all
of these different orders of magnitude
scale separation from the biggest vortex
to the tiniest vortex
in fact the reynolds number is a ratio
of the size of the largest vortex in the
flow to the tiniest vortex
so this gets bigger for higher reynolds
number flows
and you have all of these different kind
of regions
where energy transfers from big scales
to small scales and medium scales and so
on there's
energy transfer so the production range
again i said that turbulent fluctuations
are produced
from shears in the bulk flow and the
mean flow
that happens here these large structures
are pumping energy into the turbulence
and then you have these turbulent
vortices splitting and splitting and
splitting this is the inertial range
and finally you have a dissipation range
where the turbulence acts
effectively like a viscosity or at least
that's the model
and so the idea here is to basically
just chop this off at some point
don't resolve these higher frequencies
these smaller structures
and just treat them as an effective
viscosity just like we did in the rand's
equations
okay good now why would we do les over
rams
so here's a video i really like from
think fluid dynamics
that shows an les simulation on the top
and an
unsteady rand simulation on the bottom
for flow past these words
and you can see right off the bat that
the les gives you
way more detail into the flow structures
it's much more accurate especially for
shear structures and for the separated
region of the flow
in the wake so les is typically much
much more accurate
but it is obscenely expensive it is
essentially also
leveraging super computing uh super
computing resources
and so there you're using you know these
huge huge
super computers to run these less
simulations
if you have the resources and you really
want to know about separated structures
and unstudy dynamics you know this is
probably the way to go
if you can't do full dns so another les
movie i love this is um a team
from johns hopkins university stevens
game and
menovo and i pulled this from the
physics of fluids group at university of
tuente they're using
les to simulate the flow past an entire
wind farm
again there's no way we could do direct
numerical simulations at this scale
you know for these 100 meter wings or 50
meter wings
across an entire field right kilometers
long
there's no way you could do full
simulation of navier stokes
so they're going to do large eddy
simulations to understand how these
wakes interact
and how the fluid kind of vorticity
interacts in this flow
and i absolutely love this video so i'm
just going to let it play for a little
while
and i encourage you to download this for
yourself so
you know this team is doing great things
with with les
for renewable energy and lots of other
applications
but you're going to see it's going to
zoom in in a minute and we're going to
again kind of see all of the turbulent
fluctuations in this flow
now is this perfectly accurate
absolutely not this is not
a full simulation of the navy or stokes
equations this is not resolving
all space scales in space and time is it
useful for engineering to see how mixing
occurs and how the wakes
impact downstream turbines absolutely
you can use this for design and
optimization and control
i love this image where they show kind
of you can imagine a smoke line released
at a given point in time and how that
smoke would mix
downstream through the flow
and so this again just wouldn't be
possible without turbulence closure
modeling this kind of full-scale
simulation
wouldn't be possible if we tried to
simulate the full navier-stokes
equations directly okay
all right so uh one last kind of parting
thought here i pulled this
figure from uh this website cfd with a
mission
and they pulled this from a set of
slides by spell art so
spell art from the spell art allsmaran
model at boeing
this is a great picture which
essentially shows this detached eddy
simulation
model or des which was proposed
i want to say in the 70s that might not
be right maybe
maybe later but essentially this
detached eddy simulation
is built to kind of mix the best of
rands and the best of les to be more
efficient
and more accurate so when the flow is
pretty steady
and pretty kind of there's not a lot of
adverse pressure
gradient or separation you're going to
use rands and when the flow is massively
separated like this wake down here
you're going to switch to an les model
and again lots of math lots of closure
modeling to kind of match these and
combine these but this is a very cool
and useful
simulation technique as well okay great
so we've talked a lot about turbulence
closure modeling
and essentially modeling subgrid scales
and turbulent fluctuations
in terms of larger quantities of
interest
and so in the next lecture i'm going to
talk about how we're using deep learning
and deep neural networks
to start to solve and help with these
rams and les closure models to make them
more accurate
and to tailor them with actual
high-fidelity data
all right thank you